In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 24, on which we commemorate the Holy Hyromarter
Cosmas Itolos equal to the Apostles and Evangelizer of Southern Albania, the memory of
the Holy New Hyromarter and equal to the Apostles, Cosmas of Itolia.
Saint Cosmas was born in a small village in Itolia called Megadendron in the Diocese of Arta
in about the year 1714. His parents, simple and devout people, brought him up in the fear
of God and love of the Scriptures. At about the age of 20, he went to the Holy Mountain
of Athos to study at the Academy, which had been founded as a dependency of the monastery
of Vatopevi, where the famous Evgenios Bulgades was teaching. But the reactions provoked by the
founding of this establishment, which spread the spirit of the Enlightenment in the very
heart of the citadel of Orthodoxy, quickly forced Bulgades and other eminent professors
to leave Athos, and the Academy very soon fell into decline in the year 1759. This was for
the young Cosmas a sign of providence, and turning his back on his studies, he embraced the
monastic life in the monastery of Philothea, where his zeal for ascetic striving and his devotion
made him worthy to be ordained priest shortly after his monastic profession. The blessed man had,
from his youth, had a great desire to spread the word of God around him, to such a degree that he
said that the salvation of his brethren was devouring him as a grub eats away a tree from
the inside. In these difficult times for the oppressed Greek people, ignorance of the rudiments
of the faith and of Christian culture led to the neglect and decline of morals, so that the
preaching of the Gospel clearly became the most important task. But, warned by the teaching of
the fathers, Cosmas did not want to engage in apostolic life through his own will. Desiring to learn
if this was God's will, he randomly opened the holy scriptures one day, and his eyes lit on these
words of the Apostle. Let no man seek his own, but every man another's. Thus enlightened by the
word of God, and after having taken counsel of the fathers of the Holy Mountain, he went to Constantinople
to receive the blessing of patriarch Seraphim II, in the years 1759 through 1761, and to take a few
lessons in rhetoric from his cousin, Archimandrite Kessantos, who was later to become the director of the
patriarchal academy, and then of the school of Naxos. The new Apostle began his preaching ministry
in the churches around Constantinople, and pushed on into the eastern parts of Greece,
Nafbakti, Brakori, Mesolongion, and Thessaly, then returning to Constantinople. After having
withdrawn to Athos for a time, he received authorization from patriarch Sofronios II, in the years
1774 through 1780, to go and preach in the Kikladis in order to console the people who had been
discouraged by the failure of an uprising, brought about by Russia in the year 1775. He returned
thens to make a retreat in the monasteries, thus completing 17 years of life on the Holy Mountain,
but his heart, burning with love for his brethren, would not allow him to stay there. He therefore
left for Thessalonica, stayed briefly in Berea, and traveled throughout Macedonia, gathering great
crowds of the faithful who listened to him with contrition. From Kefalonia he went to the island
of Sanquithos, and then on to Corfu, going thens to Appirus. There he found that Christianity was
an apparlous state, and he confirmed the Orthodox faith there, and put a stop to the people's conversion
to Islam. Helped by God's grace, St. Cosmos worked wonders in these regions, which have to this day
remained impregnated with echoes of his preaching. Through his exhortations he succeeded in restoring
a Christian way of life to the people. His words were simple, able to be understood by all,
using images and expressions taken from everyday life, but they were also full of gentleness,
peace, and joy that can only be the gift of the Holy Spirit. They had the virtue of penetrating
straight to the souls of his hearers, and of immediately being received with enthusiasm as the
expression of the will of God. As no church would have been able to contain the crowds that gathered
round the new apostle, he preached in the open air, standing on a portable platform beside a great
cross that had been stuck in the ground, and which, after he had left, became a source of healing
and consolation for both bodily and spiritual ills. He taught the Christians to live according to
Christ's commandments, and to observe Sunday, the Lord's day, setting aside their everyday work
to go to church and hear the Word of God. Wherever he went, he founded schools, a task that he considered
fundamental for the teaching of Greek and the Holy Scriptures. He persuaded the rich to devote their
surplus to almsgiving, and the distribution of devotional books, icons, and prayer ropes,
and also urged them to donate baptisteries to the churches for the baptism of children.
A crowd of two or three thousand of the faithful followed him everywhere, becoming a veritable army
of Christ that traveled through the whole of Albania, following the saint, looking on him as
Enoch, or the prophet Elias, who had come to proclaim the dawn of a new age. Before beginning his
preaching, he would celebrate Vespers, or Aparatleses, a service of intercession to the mother of God.
Then, after having spoken, he left it to fifty or so priests who accompanied him to continue his
work by the hearing of confessions, the celebrating of the office of Holy Unction, of Holy Communion,
and personal visits to each person. Although the saint's preaching had no polemical content,
confirming itself to the teaching of the Evangelical Virtues, and also by virtue of his having
appeared before the Pasha of Yonina, and had received great honor from him. Certain Jews excited by
jealousy and furious ever since the saint had made them hold their Sunday markets on a Saturday,
persuaded the Pasha to put an end to his life. Cosmos had formed the habit of arriving in an area
in which he desired to preach, of going personally to ask the blessing of the local bishop,
and then sending one of his disciples to ask permission of the Turkish civil authorities,
arriving one day near the Albanian village of Kolikontasi. He learned that the Pasha of the region,
Kurt Pasha, lived not far away at Berati. Despite the urgings of those around him to prudence,
the saint decided to go himself and seek authorization to preach from the local official,
who made it known to him that he had received orders, to hand him over to Kurt Pasha.
On hearing these words, Saint Cosmos realized that the moment had come to crown his work
with martyrdom, and he gave thanks to Christ for having counted him worthy of such honor.
The next day, on the 24th of August in the year 1779, seven soldiers took him under escort
on the pretext of sending him to Kurt Pasha, but after two hours on the road, they stopped by the river
Pasha, and told him that he had already been sentenced to death by execution.
The saint, filled with joy and thanksgiving to God, blessed the four corners of the universe
with a sign of the cross and prayed for the salvation of all Christians. He refused to have his
hands tied so that he could cross them, and it was without offering the least resistance
that he was hanged on a tree, and gloriously gave his soul into God's keeping.
He was then 65 years old.
The Christians who had rushed to gather the saint's body, thrown into the river by his executioners,
into their nets, were left empty-handed, but a priest called Mark, being armed with prayer,
discovered the precious relics three days later, floating upright on the waves, as though the saint
were still alive. He was taken out of the water and, after being clad in his monastic habit,
was given worthy burial. A great many miracles were wrought at his tomb through the intervention of
his relics. In the year 1813, Ali Pasha of Ionina, whose glorious future Saint Kosmas had predicted,
had a church and monastery built at his tomb, and he gave his skull in a silver reliquary to his
Christian wife Basilica. Saint Kosmas, whose preaching had contributed in a decisive way to the
awakening of faith and national feeling among the Greeks, was immediately venerated by the people
as a new apostle and a prince among the new martyrs. But his veneration was only officially recognized
by the Patriarchate of Constantinople in the year 1961. Through the prayers of our holy fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.